okay so we're going to talk about this
wonderful instrument called the vuvuzela
which has been I guess criticized very
heavily in very many places though
because it features throughout all the
World Cup games people are blowing it
incessantly you can hear it very clearly
on different World Cup commentaries
try I'm not the best at this but I'll
try and get a tone Edward
like any other wind instrument that you
actually or thing that you blow into the
way it works is that you set up a
resonance of air inside the column and
it's that resonance of air that gives it
the air moving back and forth rapidly
inside the column at a particular
frequency which is set by the length of
the column may perform laptop the
microphone is being fed into a USB port
here okay so what we're going to do now
is we're going to take one phrase this
is Philip Moriarty University of
Nottingham for sixty symbols this is
Philip Moriarty University of 1960 sim
right so let's save that
so here's Fela who's a keen amateur
trombonist self-described and what he's
going to do is play a note on the
vuvuzela much better than I can three
two one
what we're going to do here is load in
that sample of my speech and we're going
to look at the frequency spectrum
University of Nottingham for sixty
symbols so what we have here is a
frequency spectrum of that free as I
said and you can see that there are lots
and lots of different Peaks spread
across this is going from a hundred
Hertz up to about three kilohertz and
those are the primary components of
maybe the playing with frequencies in my
voice we look at the vuvuzela
so if we look at this frequency spectrum
you see that it actually differs quite
substantially from the spectrum of my
voice and what we see here we've got
three very well-defined Peaks in this
spectrum this one here we call the
fundamental that's the lowest wavelength
the lowest frequency that can exist in
that tube and that's about two hundred
and twenty Hertz now I know from the
physics of that instrument that this
without even measure it that this would
be 440 twice times 220 and this would be
six roundabout 663 times 220 so that's
the fundamental what we call the second
harmonic and the third harmonic now so
what we're going to do now is wave field
players that note I'm going to try and
see the exact same phrase I said before
these are very loud instruments or I
might have to show quite a bit and then
we're going to see if we can filter out
the sound of the vuvuzela from the
center my voice right okay three two one
so that's that's the problem the
commentators have with the matches in
that you've got this incredible drone
going on all the time in the background
and you're trying to hear you trying to
make yourself heard above that drone and
so that's why the television companies
are very very interested in trying to
filter out that drone from the sound of
the voice and now what I'll do is I'll
try and take you through just how we do
that or just how the companies do it so
let's let load in that speech and
vuvuzela sample again and let's play
that back roll what I'm going to do now
is I'm going to filter out these first
tree harmonics so the one a roughly two
twenty four forty and six sixty and
let's hear what difference that makes to
the the sound universe sixty symbols so
you can hear immediately that the sound
of my voice with respect to the sound of
the vuvuzela has come up it's clearer
you can get a bit more definition but
you can still hear the vuvuzela and the
reason you can hear the Brazil is you
well you can see almost from here you
can see there as well as these three
very strong harmonics we have these
other harmonics and in fact if I blew up
the scale here you'd see that their
harmonics going all the way out here so
let's try it again
but this time instead of doing just
those three harmonics let's do eight
harmonics and see what difference that
makes
you can stand hear it in the background
and if I continue this process we could
get rid of more and more that vuvuzela
but the problem is why we're getting rid
of the vuvuzela we're also taking out
bits of the frequency spectrum
associated with my speech so you've got
to draw this balance this compromise and
that's why it's impossible to totally
decouples to
what I've shown you is something called
not filtering and the reason is called
not filtering is that we're taking
little notches out of the frequency
spectrum and getting rid of those that's
that's straight for us very simple to do
now there's a rather less reputable
company has decided that what they're
going to do is they're going to supply a
recording an mp3 of vuvuzela sound that
they argue has been recorded so it's in
anti-phase in anti-phase means that the
peaks and the troughs of the waves line
up so they're ideas that you have cancel
out those waves this is just complete
and utter nonsense if you see this on
the web and you see some sort of
recording or mp3 that you can download
for three dollars or ten dollars or
three pound or $2.99 or whatever just
don't buy it